foreign
[Music]
for our daily cancellation today we turn
to 60 minutes but not to cancel them
this time in fact 60 Minutes on Sunday
committed a rare and we must suspect
inadvertent Act of Journalism with its
report on the corrosive effects of
social media now much of their report
focused on the ways that social media
supposedly breeds anger and Division
which is not my concern personally you
know I don't think that the internet
causes or breeds anger and division so
much as it gives a forum for these
things to be made manifest in my view
that's one of social media's positive
attributes of anything people who are
angry about the direction of our country
and our culture are are you know going
to be able to voice their concerns
organize mobilize through the internet
and that's a good thing as for the
division our national divide is rooted
in the diametrically opposed worldviews
that broadly separates the two ends of
the political Spectrum it's a spectrum
that hardly even is a spectrum anymore
as a vast Chasm Cuts right down the
middle of it and this divide is
incredibly apparent on social media but
I don't think social media invented it
so the part of the 60 Minutes report
that I found important and worthwhile
was rather the section which focused on
tick tock
and its effect on children specifically
let's watch that
it's owned by a Chinese company called
bite dance and Harris says the version
that served to Chinese consumers called
durian
is very different from the one available
in the West in their version of tick
tock if you're under 14 years old
they show you science experiments you
can do at home Museum exhibits
patriotism videos and educational videos
and they also limit it to only 40
minutes per day now they don't ship that
version of tick tock to the rest of the
world so it's almost like they recognize
that technology is influencing kids
development and they make their domestic
version a spinach version of tick tock
while they've shipped the Opium version
to the rest of the world the version
served to the West has kids hooked for
hours at a time the impact Harris says
is predictable there's a survey of
pre-teens in the U.S and China asking
what is the most aspirational career
that you want to have and the US the
number one was influencer social media
influencer and in China the number one
was astronaut
again you allow those two societies to
play out for a few Generations I can
tell you what your world is going to
look like Tick Tock tells us it gives
American users tools to limit screen
time but those tools are entirely
voluntary
so nothing to see here except that Tick
Tock is a communist psyop aimed at
making our children shallow and stupid
and not just shallow and stupid because
the other incredibly significant effect
of social media not just Tick Tock of
course
on our kids is that it is yet one more
Force separating them from us as the
parents this is the aspect not discussed
nearly enough and which is rarely
mentioned in news reports lamenting
rampant social media addiction among
kids
they often leave this part out you know
the average kid spends nine hours a day
consuming media of various kinds usually
through their phone
and if you're anything like the
statistically average parent then you
have really no clue about the nature of
the images sounds and ideas that he
ingests during that spin
and naturally we take this all for
granted we assume that this Dynamic is
is natural and normal and basically
healthy
our children exist in their own worlds
their own culture their own language
their own value system their own
celebrities
they become disciples in the Cults of
various idiots on YouTube or Tick Tock
or wherever all of these figures obscure
to us and we imagine that this is just
how it inevitably must be
there's no other feasible option we
think
and we're wrong
because while it's true that older
Generations have always worried about
the younger and the younger Generations
have always exhibited characteristics
that older Generations find puzzling and
troubling
it's not true
that young people have always existed as
they do now in their own universes their
own societies with their own leaders and
icons and Prophets their own religions
their own Customs all of it designed to
be indecipherable and inaccessible to
the older Generations
in fact in the bad old days kids were if
you can imagine it
raised by their parents almost
exclusively not by the internet or TV or
even Public School
kids didn't have a whole life separate
apart from their mothers and fathers
they may have had friends a few not 40
not four thousand
but uh it was their parents who exerted
the most influence over the making and
shaping and forming them as parents are
supposed to do and things started to
change with modern schooling which sent
kids out of the home for most of their
young lives and you know into the care
of strangers
and then a divide became between
Generations became even more vast with
pop culture as kids began to develop
tastes that differed so dramatically
from their parents yet even then
it wasn't like it is now
because yeah kids in the 50s and 60s
they worshiped uh you know Elvis as a
God and they their parents thought that
Elvis was ancient agent of Satan but
their parents at least knew who Elvis
was Elvis was accessible equally to both
parent and child you saw him on TV you
saw you heard him on the radio
you know you bought his music at the
store and and that was about it that's
how you encountered him and then the
internet and now kids have their own
version of Elvis they have like in fact
a lot of Elvis's a lot of little Elvises
that they follow in worship and imitate
just as kids of the 50s and 60s did
but they encounter these new icons in
the void of cyberspace mostly on their
phones out of sight
and there isn't just one Elvis but 400
and they pop up and fade away and change
on a dime the trends move at the speed
of light and the only way to follow
along is to be totally immersed in it
and surrendered to it
the religion of leftism is anti-religion
which means that there isn't anyone to
turn to when things don't go the way
there's no Transcendent being pointing
you toward truth and Beauty there are no
Customs or Traditions to keep you on a
righteous path and there's certainly no
app like hallow to help leftists reclaim
their peace hallow is an audio guided
prayer and meditation app it's the
number one Christian Prayer app in the
U.S hallow is like calm or headspace but
without all the woke nonsense because
it's rooted in Christian faith with
thousands of meditations and prayers I
use hollow to find peace after a long
day of being yelled at by blue-haired
zazen weirdos they have over 5 000 audio
guided prayers meditations and Christian
music you can pray alongside Jim
Caviezel Jonathan Ruby Bishop Baron
father Mike Schmitz and Mark Wahlberg
hello helps me make a make prayer a
priority in my life and they can do the
same for you so get an exclusive
three-month trial hello.com Matt Walsh
that's hello.com Matt Walsh reclaim your
piece in this crazy world download hello
today
so our kids are are pulled along
by these forces they're shaped and
molded by forces that we don't see or
understand and we as parents are
rendered irrelevant
because of the child's phone
in fact if your child is on his phone
nine hours a day it's the phone
and the people that he interacts with
and watches when he uses it that will
form him it's the phone that parents him
your second fiddle at best
and he's not going to hear the tune
you're playing because he's on his phone
anyway
so this is not normal it's not healthy
it's not natural
it's not how it's always been
there's really nothing quite analogous
to this in the history of human society
like the the idea of one
Gadget one sort of Little Portal that
kids carry around in their in their
pockets
taking over their lives to this extent
there's no analogy in history
our kids are being destroyed by these
gadgets that we spend exorbitant amounts
of money to provide to them
and I think we have no idea how bad it's
going to get as our lives migrate more
and more into our phones and our
children are resigned to an existent
that existence that can barely be called
human at this point
so
what do we do about it well I think
there are two possible paths forward
there's the path that most parents today
seem to take
which is that you just sort of go with
it
your hand your child the phone with
internet access when he's nine or ten or
whatever you know whenever most of his
friends get one and you give them one
two because they don't want them to feel
left out and you just trust it'll work
out okay
sure he's like 100 guaranteed to develop
a porn habit sure he'll spend all day
absorbing messages and ideas that are
anathema to his intellectual and
spiritual and emotional development sure
his entire life will now revolve around
this damned thing sure all of that is
true but but what's the other option to
deprive him of this technology that
everyone else uses that would make him
look uncool
worse it would make the parent look
uncool
people might think that you're you're
poor and you can't afford one
and the trends how can your family keep
up with the trends without the phone
you can't be on trendy you can't let
your kids be on trendy dear God anything
but untrendiness
so that's one path
and if you take that path and you know
you then Tick Tock is going to remain a
problem in your life and your family for
your kids
but then number two the other option is
the path Less Traveled
the path that some people would consider
extreme
uh keep your kid away
from the internet as much as humanly
possible
don't let them have the internet on his
phone
don't let them access the internet in
his room
give them access to one computer
strictly controlled in a visible area of
the house
which he can use with your permission
for a limited amount of time with the
knowledge that you the parent will
review his internet history after he's
finished and go back and watch any
videos he watched and click on the links
he clicked and and read every message he
received
give him no privacy on the internet at
all none
don't trust your child with the internet
that's the worst thing you could do
treat the internet like a very powerful
and potentially dangerous tool which it
is
and treat him like a child who can't be
allowed to use it unsupervised which he
is
so that's the other option
and the great thing is that 60 minutes
talking about Tick Tock and all these
different things
if you take that option then you don't
need to worry about Tick-Tock nearly as
much
and so I think that option is probably
the best
and I say that as somebody who makes a
living on the internet
so with all that said what is canceled
today
well I guess parents who give their kids
phones are once again we must say
canceled
so that'll do it for this portion of the
show I hope you get out and uh vote but
before you do we'll get over to our
member block of the program and I hope
to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]